the question that leads into this is
it's asking exactly the same question
but they just take the zero they say
what power of two is a factor of 10
factorial you can say oh okay 10
factorial you get a number and you can't
wait up and then you can start to work
with it and work out eyes 2 to the power
1 2 squared 2 cubed etc and you'll
arrive at a number okay bye then see
this is what I was talking about before
right they give you a hundred which is
like taking this right and just
increasing the powers beyond the reach
of what you can do by hand kind of okay
your calculator can't accept 100
factorial it just probably said to you
that error in fact on my calculator
anyway my calculator can't even do 70
factorial it just says forget it which
we shouldn't be surprised by it is
factorial after all and when we
introduced actual notation we saw how
quickly it skyrockets so hundred
factorial it's a big number but here's
the great thing right we are
mathematicians we are more than just
calculators we can do things that had I
said it I was about to say we can do
things that our brains can't handle you
can see you can consider things which in
the concrete are too big to imagine but
abstractly you can still work with you
so let's have a go at this what power of
two is a factor of a hundred factorial
now I want to come back to the original
question right of 10 okay now what's
this number let me just actually write
down what the number is okay no this
number is just barely big enough that
you can work with this and if I asked
you to for instance give me the prime
factorization of this number think back
to like you seven or eight when you had
to define like greatest common divisor
although it's called a lot you can break
this up into all of the prime numbers
two 3s 5 7 etc that aren't factors and
you can do that uniquely ok the
calculator will help you but when you
get to this it's too big so I want to
use this as a case study that we can
develop an approach that work here right
that we can bring to here now if I just
gave
this number I said okay factorize right
what would you do well you you put punch
the number in and you just start
dividing my numbers until you've got
something reasonable you'd say oh okay I
can clearly divide that by say a hundred
so you stick one hundred over here and
three six two and you can say well I
could divide up a hundred what would you
like me to divide up day we can do look
at the exact 25 in fall and then you do
this okay I'm starting to must've
familiar with your cell phone I can do I
can do let's see four and something
whatever it is okay and then you would
just keep going but you just keep going
except this is a silly thing to do if
you thought you know that this number is
10 factorial because if I told you from
the outset but this number is 10
factorial you don't have to monkey
through this whole process you know what
all of these numbers are right because
10 factorial is in fact equal to 10 by 9
8 7 etcetera right it's already been hey
presto factorized before you even begin
okay now admittedly because you've got
tens and nines and each day which a
bunch of your numbers you'd like to do a
little bit of work but not that much
and I think about it let's go from the
top Tim is a factor of early is it's
only two primes in it right that's two
times five all right no that's just
three squared H that's too cute right
you could do four times do we have to go
down again 7 is prime 6 is 2 5 3 4 is 2
squared and that's the last composite
number the rest of prime okay so now I
have my factorization sitting in front
of me I need to put it together with
less sexually I'm done now remember all
I'm after at the moment anyhow is the
powers of 2 the factor to do how many
fit in there ok this is not hard to cut
one two three four five six seven right
they're all there right the
factorization is given to you there are
eight no more one okay now hold on this
approach this approach this will work
with this number it will still be large
right but it's it's doable it's
definitely do and there are things you
can do to reduce this right you noticed
I wrote out the whole 10 factorial right
but I didn't really need to write only
some of its parts
there were ten pieces I you notice I
already skipped off
I only write down nine right I knew I
didn't have to need I didn't require the
gun because it's just one doesn't add
anything useful but there are other
numbers I could have cut out the process
right I'm looking for powers of two I
can reduce this by half can I
which numbers should I cut out cut cut
out all the odds right there they're
gonna contribute a factor of two right
so I okay now this problem is starting
to become manageable there are other
things you can do which can speed up the
process as well I have a look here
you've got two four and eight at least
in this zhuzh which are special right
and you can work out very quickly what
their powers are going to be let's see
I'll write them down here 2 4 8 16 32 64
and I don't need to do any more ok how
many factors of 2 will each one
contribute well this is gonna give you
one and this one's gonna give you two
and then this one's gonna give you three
and so on ok now if I were just taking
like if I multiplied all of these
numbers together which I don't know what
it's equal to
let's see what is it
18:23 okay so this is a big number right
but I don't need to know if the number
is equal to to know what power of two
will be able to fat guys into it I can
just say 1 3 6 10 15 20 huh did that
series of numbers seem familiar there
you go r21
sorry to sit to the 21 will take
Internet okay and then I've got all my
other knee even numbers so I'm gonna
have to add them all in but that's okay
that's that's doable right at the end
when you add up these and all of your
honor let's see what have I left in 612
cetera okay you can add up all of those
as well when you do them and you count
out you separate out how many powers of
two you're gonna get in there well
you'll find there are 97 okay so that
process that's the underwater part it
does take it could be the time okay but
just sort out who's trying to do it the
long way right the way that doesn't take
advantage of what 10 factorial is
actually equal to it hundred factorial
is equal to vs. what onwards you can way
of actually going through this and
trying to reduce the size of the problem
so except let's think about this I have
all my powers of two okay but there are
other numbers in the list like these
guys right then are not powers of two
and they will contribute factors right
more twos right so how do I go through
them logically without just listing them
out let's think about this I'll go from
the bottom the biggest numbers to the
top you see why in a second if there are
any multiples of 64 within this number
it's very very big number if there are
any multiples of 64 they will contribute
I know exactly how many twos they will
contribute right for instance if I said
just as any tab which I know doesn't
work but um three times 64 what's that
that's a 180 200 okay now because I have
told you that it's three times 64 right
that's three to the power x to the power
six right so I don't care about the
three I'm only interested in the twos
right
this being a multiple of 64 gives me the
same number of two's that's 64 does does
that make sense
say it say it again right beam this is a
multiple of 64 and there are no more
two's that I can feel it to that right
in what contribute exactly the same
number of two factors the 64 will
contribute
now how many multiples of 64 are there
underneath 100 there's only one namely
64 soon as you go to the next multiple
your eights you do okay so I'm just
gonna say times 132 thank you how do
multiples of 32 are there now you can
just do a hundred divided by 32 and it's
three in a bit so there are three but
don't forget I've counted one of them
already right right so in fact there are
only two left only 32 and and 96 so I'm
gonna say there are two of those that
haven't counted okay come to this guy
16 how many multiples of 16 are there
there will be six but I've counted one
two three of them already right
how many multiples
how many multiples of eight are there
then answer the question for me there
are 12 right because I can go let's
let's count them out have enough I can
go 8 16 24 32 40 48 56 64 72 eighty
eighty eight ninety six and then I'm
finished
so there are 12 12 how many have I
already counted how many multiples
before
there are 25 how many have I already
counted I've already counted 12 so there
are 13 left all right last one
how many multiples of 2 how many do I
have left
okay so all of the ones that I haven't
counted in here they'll contribute one
factor of 25 and these okay shoot 2 & 3
& 4 & 5 & 6
let's hope my numbers work 25 26 1812 10
6 huh ok let's see 30 51 1697
thank you thank you alright so so look
see see where the logic is resist resist
steam patents one two three
where they aren't necessarily patents
okay and reduce down the question I like
and you're really gonna list out one to
100 no you're gonna list that true -
like etc are you really gonna stand out
nerve is a much much more might go bad